hello friends bros rich at chose believe
it or not there are more simulator games
out there ready to be covered and ready
to change your our lives so let's play
them together get ready for room
cleaning simulator yay all right room
cleaning simulator you can barely see
your floor under all this garbage what
am I supposed to do I can move oh my god
it's me I'm stuck here
what am I done get a me DVD all right
I'm gonna [ __ ] clean this [ __ ] up
this is practically a York Raeleen in
real life anyway this is probably the
most realistic simulator out of them all
you just shove all your [ __ ] into the
corner this is literally me before I
start making videos just shove all that
[ __ ] away from the feel of you and then
I can sign alright I don't get all of it
but that's good enough alright how's it
going race funny Me's be where this is
pretty awesome later yeah
Bridge League alright that was a 10 and
10 next up super squared simulator no
get up no no no no alright
my username damn yes alright then
I don't why how does one squat that was
so sexy
this is it isn't it cuz anything else
happened
oh oh oh my god this is amazing
minecraft minecraft is not gonna stay in
a change today's oh yeah baby oh yeah oh
oh hey white gonna squash God Squad why
don't you ask girl then [ __ ] watch what
your aides and the sweats coach one is
gonna get their grumpiest airs gonna get
it so Jenga gonna rub it with butter
euler spider or girl uh-huh
water all girl uh-huh butter old girl
huh gotta rub my butter wheel around for
our roll girl there it is own [ __ ]
thing all day every day by the hour girl
butter oil girl click it in my butt from
my bot chick flick it from my butt
cheeks oh okay yes look at naked trick
upon my butt cheese you are in her I
thank you oh my god this game was really
a lot more than what we could see I
drugs have never been close to this
effect before not that I would know any
of that
I sold my pants what else you want I'm
done I'm give this I love 11 out of 10
next up virtual cat collecting simulator
2000 version 1.1 and is out there it is
it's working
think it's doing something hello oh
there we go thank you
this game needs no introduction let's
display no [ __ ] way I can be magic
goal collect all the cats I love that
kitty
alright I've collected that one and I
collected that one and that one and that
one and that one and that one and that
one didn't I collect all the [ __ ] let's
get all the [ __ ] this is kind of like
real life for boys you lose why the [ __ ]
did I the anime there's an anime best
game ever ten out of ten
they need a minute date date date Eddie
haha bikini
give me kitty ah yes yes ah come here
you son of a [ __ ]
ah almost gotcha I'm gonna get ya
yes thank you alright this is gonna hurt
a poor man care I don't know the lyrics
but some Swedish
let's lie lie lie yah should be hair
Meli Oh Dan sabotage clap power and
there ya dumb [ __ ] ma oh I'm sorry
all right next up smoking simulator this
is just a demo cuz apparently they're
making a full version out of this
smoking simulator alright you know what
I like to live life on the edge
let's go so far I am pretty blown away
get it
alright smoking causes lung cancer heart
is okay day one
alright so it's actually a game publish
it alright hello what am I supposed to
do here I'll guess I'll get to my office
well son of a [ __ ] alright you know
what
gotta go today alright oh [ __ ]
maybe I shouldn't have done that with a
controller where is he where is the best
hello
alright why did he read I said now I'll
shut up a batch what the [ __ ] is he in
here
hello can I meet the boss please go to
the boss the boss is very yeah I'm
coming holy shed
damn the boss really loves himself
is that mr. bones mr. burns is that Jill
I've really got a smoke right now rage
mode what does that even mean ah did I
just throw shut up a badge
must destroy my sister and you're laying
out your bet you chatted I'm back I hate
you huh I hit you on your son a buck oh
my god
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] ah ah ah
best game ever 10/10 alright here we
have Brendan simulator it looks really
good alright the graphics remind me of
meth and the very first NES alright
Brendan goes on skype to talk to his
friends Brendan realize that everyone he
messes messages goes on do not disturb
or Brandon Brendan Christ
bravo Bravo Bravo Bravo so change
everything oh my god let's play it again
all right let's Brendan looks up a new
game to play and Brendan finds a game
called Brendan simulator Brendan
realizes that the whole game is very
realistic Christ all right then
Brendan looks at poster and that feels
train comes at him at full speed Christ
oh my god poor poor Brendan he just
cries of everything Brendan looks at the
four controllers he has Brendan realize
that no one ever wants to play with him
Christ Oh for [ __ ] sake [ __ ] that King
actually like the tune the two wasn't
bad so yeah I'll give it a 10 out of 10
it's funny how I'm actually like despite
these games being really bad they're
still enjoyable for me to play let's
depart a drinker simulator party drinker
simulator can you find all the secrets
probably not oh jesus [ __ ] christ
it looks like I've already done all the
drinking hello
no I can pee on people hello there's
nothing move you know what if you ever
want someone to move just [ __ ] pee on
alright lava can be disrupted by the
simplest of actions as perhaps being on
someone
sometimes your affection actions affect
other people and sometimes they don't
this is how DJ's literally do their job
it's not right Skrillex why did you go
through the wall
Skrillex broke the matrix goddamnit
Skrillex always got to do some
mainstream [ __ ] this is not how you take
mirror selfies this is how you do it you
pee in your mouth
alright I'm too lazy to find the secrets
alright so this game is quite a find
because it's been rated ten out of ten
by the game developer and it says the
title may be misleading the game is
ultra black grass simulator altar glass
simulator 2014
oh [ __ ] off
here we are cow petting sim can't wait
to [ __ ] penetrate that cow oh wow
what a nice little cow come here oh god
oh god I just came a little bit sorry
about dad cow you know what it's like
milking don't you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's a great cow uh oh [ __ ] i bleep ed
it two out of ten cows get up oh god oh
god
uh uh ah it happened it happens it
happens that does not mean I like it
even though I did like it a lot this is
like pokemons except you're fisting cows
Oh God
right there right in front of my eyes I
got him running out of Dow oh why me
everything in life doesn't matter
anymore
alright last but not least taco
simulator I'm pretty excited about this
one all the other games that I forgot to
rate a 10 out of 10 there we go let's
just [ __ ] play ad youngish ed all
right you want some tomato up in that
[ __ ] I'll stack that [ __ ] for you
you want some lattice I give you ladders
[ __ ] you want some you want some
mystery meat I give you mystery meat
[ __ ] she wants a shudder [ __ ] I give
you a shadow [ __ ] you want some of this
alright finalized you're welcome
you want some tacos find a nice you're
welcome you want some you want some
[ __ ] cheese I give you cheese you
want some potato fries give you potato
fries you want my boogers that's
actually impressively sacked got a
headed to myself get it handed right now
oh it's a mystery meat this is actually
just my diarrhea from yesterday next
well this has been eye-opening hope you
guys enjoy this little video go ahead
and look like we did if you don't I will
cry and if you do I will wait just I
don't know
just do whatever you want I don't care
stay awesome bros thank you for watching
it means a lot brofist